starting off this hour is going to be
Alisha in North Carolina hi Alicia how
are you hi David good how are you
better than I deserve what's up not much
I have a situation I'm hoping you can
settle a dispute between me and my
husband so he has recently started going
to the gym and is very passionate about
what he does but he's eating me out of
house and home so we're in baby set 1
I'm just trying to rationalize or have
you tell me if I'm being crazy or not
should I mean should he cut his
supplement and his weekly spending to
help us fund our emergency fund or that
maybe into irrational what is your
household income so grace is about
seventy four thousand a year and what is
he spending on the gym and on
supplements so it's six hundred dollars
between his food for the week and
supplements for the month and that's $39
gym membership food for the week yes so
that's $100 every day week mm-hmm every
$10 per week
oh right every day they're $100 a day
right no no I'm sorry
$600 is $100 a day it's $400 a month
just for his food four per week so make
sense no actually the per month or per
week it can't be per month per week
$1.00 in groceries per month and then
200 in supplements per month okay well
he's gonna eat 400 dollars in groceries
a month anyway most humans do okay what
do you eat the additional for me and my
daughter is 200 in addition to what he
hears stuff how old is your daughter
keeping okay she doesn't eat much all
right
not a lot so yeah I mean a normal
grocery budget in North Carolina would
be 508 and
a month okay for the groceries and if
you want if you guys want to trim that
back that's fine we can talk that
through the gym is $39 that's not
killing you the supplements probably are
high right that's probably um you know
how long has he been a workout fiend
this is going his third one third months
correct okay is he trying to lose weight
or what's his goal his goal is to
compete in a bodybuilding competition
starting from scratch three months ago
right so he's had some history off and
on but he's really been dedicated the
last three months actually okay and how
much debt do you guys have we are about
sixty two thousand dollars in bit and
how much do you own your cars about
forty thousand of that and on which cars
29 on mine and roughly just under ten on
his okay so if you're keeping a twenty
nine thousand dollar car which
represents half of your debt load when
you make seventy five thousand dollars a
year I think that's a bigger deal than
supplements absolutely okay so um the
what I'm hearing here is is you guys are
just getting started on the whole
budgeting thing and you haven't yet both
agreed that the big goal in the house is
getting rid of this debt you're not on
the same page right and that's leading
to the disagreement see when when when
we both agree that this is what we're
trying to do then we start looking at
$29,000 cars and is there another way to
do supplements where I can still hit my
goal on my bodybuilding or do I need to
put it off for a few months and then get
started again you know you start to say
I'm gonna set aside things that I used
to think were necessary in order to hit
our big goal of getting out of debt you
guys are not doing that yet if you can
get agreement on that
it's gonna solve a lot of these things
but I don't think you're gonna win a
200-dollar supplement battle while
you're driving between ten thousand
dollar car
matter of fact I'm sure you're not so um
yeah I think the car is a lot bigger
problem than the supplements if I'm in
your all shoes hey thanks for the call